hey youtubers it's Charlie and this week
for my continuing exploration of the
Marvel movie universe I thought it'd be
fun to talk about the Doctor Strange
movie they haven't announced it
officially but behind every rumor is a
little bit of truth they are meeting
with almost every major actor in
Hollywood or at least every major actor
that could pull off a movie about magic
so in this video I'm going to talk about
my top 5 Doctor Strange stories that I
think would make a very good first movie
for the character because they have to
tell the origin story first then I'll
address some of the casting rumors if
you are finding me for the first time
I'll be doing Marvel movie videos every
Tuesday in addition to my agents of
shield videos so be sure to subscribe
enjoy the fun so here we go top 5 Doctor
Strange stories number 5 the essential
Doctor Strange vol 1 this is the
collected works of Stan Lee and Steve
Ditko's original run on the character
the original origin story expect to see
a Stan Lee cameo in the movie and at
least some Easter eggs if not straight
up lines from the characters in these
stories because it was written in the
early 60s this became a benchmark for
weird and comic books right now I think
guardians of the galaxy is trying to do
that for superhero movies almost every
subsequent retelling of the Doctor
Strange origin story borrows some
aspects from Stan Lee's original so the
movie will at least pay homage to these
stories one notable change that I expect
to see would be the shortening of the
long prose speeches Stan Lee likes to
talk a lot and Stan Lee's Doctor Strange
consequently talked a lot
so yes expect any movie version of the
character to speechify say a little bit
more than Hulk and a little bit less
than a Chatty Tony Stark number four
triumphant torment they'd have to change
the story just a little bit but it
involves Doctor Doom getting dr.
Strange's help to rescue his mother from
Mephisto it was done by a hell boys Mike
Mignola and it reads like super high
drama romance you know Downton Abbey
style crossed with a dream you could
only have if you were super high
what premise could be cooler than Doctor
Strange and Doctor Doom going to hell
Mephisto like Dormammu is a really big
villain in the Doctor Strange universe
so I'll be curious to see if they keep
those types of characters in the movie
they did cut the Mandarin out of the
original Iron Man movie and they would
have to swap dr. new for someone else
because that's a Fantastic Four
character that Marvel does not currently
own number three a separate reality most
people refer to this as Frank brothers
run he was the artist but not the writer
I would definitely put it up
with brine cave-ins run on the character
which would come later the story is an
excellent blend of a lot of the science
fiction aspects of the Marvel Universe
and the fantasy elements of magic
strange ends up fighting this other
sorcerer who's trying to become a god
and it really reminds me of the original
Infinity Gauntlet storyline where you
know villain tries to achieve ultimate
power so that he can fill this hole
inside himself
you know replace something that's
missing in the case of that it was loved
and ultimately it turns into a story
about Redemption
for all you anime fans out there it also
really reminded me a Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood it's stories like
this that make me really excited to see
how an enlightened being like Strange is
going to deal with a man of pure science
like Tony Stark but that's really the
job of whoever ends up writing the
script you know blending the fantasy
elements with science fiction really
well like original Star Wars trilogy
style number 2 flight of bones this was
actually part of the really noir Marvel
Knights miniseries era and invoke this
really cool detective story setting for
Doctor Strange going after Dormammu
think of it as being like Doctor Strange
ridden like a Sherlock Holmes story and
my number one pick both by Brian cave on
this was an amazing retelling of the
origin story that solved the really
problematic aspects of magic from a
story standpoint by not making them the
focus of the story it also does a great
job of balancing the more philosophical
aspects of wielding limitless power with
the fun magical battles and action
sequences and other dimensions the big
issue with a darker strange story that's
different from say a Captain America
story is that he can't punch his
problems away he has to bounce really
dark power with white magic the really
good part about that though is that it
blends really well with the idea of the
infinity gems the Infinity Gauntlet and
Thanos in Avengers 3 if you want to
learn more about a recent story like
that you should also check out dr.
Strange's recent appearances in New
Avengers and Marvel's infinity series
it's essentially an Illuminati story so
I could totally see them using that as
inspiration for how all these new
different heroes come together in outer
space for Avengers 3 now it's your turn
though let me know which Doctor Strange
story would you like to see them use for
the darker strange movie and how do you
think they'll change it just to make it
a little bit more modern now let's talk
a little bit about those actor rumors
just to address the Johnny Depp rumors
that have been going around Kevin Feige
said that he did have a meeting a long
long time ago before his tenure
Marvel before they ever created their
unified movie universes in their faces
so if they do end up getting a big actor
it will probably be someone else we
could totally talk about actors in
another video but there are a lot of
other phase 3 movies and development
that we can talk about like say the
black widow movie or the Black Panther
movie or we could keep talking about
guardians of the galaxy so let me know
what you want to see in next week's
phase 3 video if you want to talk about
another movie or more Doctor Strange
actors or something completely different
right now click here to get my top 5
picks for our story for Captain America
3 and click here to get my character
breakdown or the guardians of the galaxy
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you